[Music]
look if
you get to the end of the day and you
know in your head
think oh i could have made this better i
could have been or had this been i could
have asked this better i could have been
more
empowering here i could have trusted a
little bit more here like if you don't
have like
10 of those at the end of the day i
think you're just walking through life
clueless
[Music]
if you don't think every day
now i'm not saying like i made a
decision launch
the columbia shuttle and people died
i it doesn't need to be that dramatic
but you can make it better you can be
better every day
you you just move on yeah sometimes you
don't need to apologize just
move forward be be better i
made a public commitment to my team to
be a better leader to not tell them what
my thing was don't give any orders
if i tell you guys what to do do i want
you guys to
to call me out on that i want you to
yellow card whatever behavior you do
they're gonna do
so do you want if your team makes a
mistake do you want them to come tell
you about it or would you rather they
just hide it
yeah okay you you whatever behavior you
do they're gonna do
so if you make a mistake you come clean
you say hey i could have done better
should
i i wasn't in a good frame of mind when
i was running this meeting
i didn't really do a very good job
listening in my opinion it was brought
up to me or maybe
just self-reflecting on it then
it is not what you would want your
people to do as leaders we have this
we have this arrogant asymmetry in our
perspectives well
i'm going to be like this but you have
to be like like that
and it turns out there's like there's a
underlying pattern
all these different things that we say
and the pattern is
they're structured from an industrial
age era
with the objective two objectives
one is to reduce variability collapse
variability and uncertainty as soon as
possible which often means prematurely
and two there's a coercive nature
because the industrial age
organization was designed so that one
group of people
made decisions and a different group of
people just
had to implement the decisions that were
determined by the first group of people
and it looks like this this is your
industrial age factory you have all
these people these are people doing what
they're told
this one person over here the foreman is
a person who's telling people
what to do so the point is in that model
it's all cool it's coercive we don't say
it we use oh it's motivational it's
inspirational
whatever but it's fundamentally about
getting someone else to do something you
decided they needed to do
and it hit me like a light like just a
ton of bricks like that's the model it
doesn't have to be that way
[Music]
we can let the people who are doing the
work make decisions about the work how
do we do that
we know it's better and it came out
through language and so i
what i think is my hypothesis
is that our language is an industrial
age language and you can do everything
you want to claim to be in an
enlightened workplace and then the light
leader but unless you
actually change the words you say now
this is the easiest and the hardest
thing to do
you don't need software you don't need
to change the laws of physics but you
have to change your habits
and there's so many people myself
included
that you just stuck and you
you're stuck in the patterns there's
some people for example who like to say
the word
right so they're there right and then
they're right
right no
wrong why do we have to well first of
all why are we saying right
it's a coercion it's a micro coercion to
piggyback on another genre it's a micro
coercion because
it's just saying if you don't think this
is right
you're the odd person out you and and i
just make a little harder for people to
disagree
yeah the structure of meetings where we
talk about something and then we vote
is inherently coercive
because the conversation makes it harder
for us
for the outliers to speak up we
want it to be because i'm not really
truly honestly interested
in a real conversation so i say hey we
should launch 737 max software right i
mean
we've done a lot of testing testing off
i mean you
one of our clients is a global
construction company and
for anyone in construction and anyone
can imagine a construction site there's
a lot of top-down do-it-yourself kind of
stuff
and every morning the team gets together
so i was
uh i would observe these meetings and so
one morning
i was in boston observing a meeting and
it was a bunch of carpenters
and the foreman walks in and
he's a little bit of a younger guy but
he takes a very gruff
tone he uses the f-bomb about 15 times
in the
five minute so we're gonna do this this
this this this this this this
uh you good go
now you good it's not really a question
you i wouldn't put a question mark after
it if i were writing it
it means you better be good
and you're on your way i'm not no one
had any questions
the safety head safety guy got up and he
said he asked six
questions immediately in a row
immediately went on the next one so you
got the tools you need right you don't
want anyone's hard hat to blow up do you
and like again no one said anything 40
people
no one said anything and afterwards i
was like
dude were you really looking for
responses to those questions
oh yeah they're just um the problem is
these are these binary questions is it
say uh is it safe
yeah yeah are you sure yeah so you gotta
say
how safe is it so we changed it so on
the on the construction site
because no one's going to no one
literally no one's going to say
it's not safe to work today we have a
storm blowing in we have five new people
we're going up on the third deck
there's no railings it's not safe but if
you ask every day you say how safe is it
zero to five and people are going five
five five and then one day they say
four it's easy to do that
now you're like oh something's changed
we were talking to a doctor's
organization in seattle so this one
covet hit
and uh one enlightened doctor started
asking her team the rest of them were
like
you guys are good right you're good
right and they would all say
yeah they would all pretend to be good
they weren't good
they were nervous some of them had when
and when they had elderly parents they
would go home so be exposed as
healthcare workers they would go home
interact with elderly parents they were
super scared
so this one doctor says how safe do you
feel not are you safe
they're putting up one person puts up
with zero that takes guts
but a zero you know first of all thank
you you're the first person that ever
asked me that
and number two and she told the story it
was with this el
i my my mom lives with me if i get sick
she's gonna die i will know that i
killed her can i
work in a dif can i do something anyway
so
the idea so that's fistify you got to
ask your questions in a probabilistic
way we say start the question with the
word how.
i'll say don't tell people just so that
that'll make your questions better
[Music]
right
you